so ernest becker i'm not sure if you're
familiar with the philosopher he wrote
the book denial of death and his idea is
that one of the core motivations of
human beings is our terror of death our
fear of death
that's what makes us unique from cats
cats are just surviving they do not have
a
deep
unders like uh
cognizance
introspection that
over the horizon is the end
and he says that i mean there's a terror
management theory that just all these
psychological experiments that show
basically
this idea that
all of human civilization everything we
create is kind of trying to forget if
even for a brief moment that we're going
to die
when do you think humans
understand that they're going to die is
it learned early on
also like
i don't
know at what point i mean it's a it's a
question like you know at what point do
you realize that you know what death
really is and i think most people don't
actually realize what death is right i
mean most people believe that you go to
heaven or something right well so the so
to push back on that
what ernest becker says and um sheldon
solomon all of those folks
and i find those ideas a little bit
compelling is that there is moments in
life early in life a lot of this fun
happens early in life
when you
are when you do deeply experience the
terror of this realization and all the
things you think about about religion
all those kinds of things that we kind
of think about more like teenage years
and later
we're talking about way earlier no it's
like seven or eight years or something
like that yeah you realize
holy crap
this is uh like the mystery the terror
like it's almost like you're a little
prey a little baby deer sitting in the
darkness of the jungle of the woods
looking all around you there's darkness
full of terror i mean that's that
realization says okay i'm going to go go
back in the comfort of my mind where
there is a well there is a deep meaning
where there is a
maybe like
pretend i'm immortal in however way
however kind of idea i can construct to
help me understand that i'm immortal
religion helps with that you can you can
delude yourself in all kinds of ways
like lose yourself in the busyness of
each day have little goals in mind all
those kinds of things to think that it's
going to go on forever and you kind of
know you're going to die yeah and it's
going to be sad but you don't really
understand that you're going to die and
so that's that's their idea and i find
that compelling
because it does seem to be a core unique
aspect of human nature that we were able
to think that we're going we're able to
really understand
that this life is finite
that seems important
there's a bunch of different things
there so first of all i don't think
there is a qualitative difference
between between us and cats in the term
i think the difference is that we just
have a better long-term
ability to
predict you know in the long term and so
we have a better understanding of how
the world works so we have better
understanding of you know finance of
life and things like that so we have a
better planning engine than cats yeah
okay um yeah but what's the motivation
for
for planning well i think it's just a
side effect of the fact that we have
just a better planning engine because it
makes us uh as i said you know the
essence of intelligence is the ability
to predict and so the because we're
smarter
as a side effect we also have this
ability to kind of make predictions
about our own
future existence or lack thereof okay
you say religion helps with that i think
religion hurts actually um it makes
people worry about like you know what's
gonna happen after their death etc
if you believe that you know uh you just
don't exist after that so like you know
it solves completely the problem at
least you're saying if you don't believe
in god you don't worry about what
happens after death yeah
i don't know you want to worry about the
about uh you know this life because
that's the only one you have
i think it's well i don't i don't know
if i were to say what ernest becker says
and i said i agree with him more
uh than not is um
you do deeply worry
uh if you if you believe there's no god
there's still a deep worry like of the
mystery of it all like how does that
make any sense that it just ends i don't
think we can
truly understand
that this ride i mean so much of our
life the consciousness the ego
is uh invested in this in this being and
then
science keeps bringing humanity down
from its pedestal
and yeah but that's another another
example of it that's wonderful but for
us individual humans we don't like to be
brought down from a pedestal you're
saying like
but see you're fine with it because well
so what ernest becker would say is
you're fine with it because that's just
a more peaceful existence for you but
you're not really fine you're hiding
from in fact some of the people that
experience the deepest trauma
uh that
earlier in life
they often before they seek extensive
therapy will say i'm fine it's like when
you talk to people who are truly angry
how are you doing i'm fine
the question is what's going on
now i had a near-death experience i had
a very bad uh motorbike accident when it
was 17 so
but that didn't have any impact on
my
reflection on that topic so i'm i'm
basically just playing a bit of a
devil's advocate pushing back and
wondering
is it truly possible to accept death and
the flip side that's more interesting i
think for ai and
robotics is how important is it to have
this as one of the suite of motivations
is to
not just avoid
falling off the roof or something like
that but
ponder
the
the end of the ride
if you listen to the stoics
it's uh it's a great motivator
it adds a sense of urgency so it might
be to truly fear death or be cognizant
of it
might give
uh a deeper meaning and urgency to the
moment to live
fully
well
maybe i don't disagree with that i mean
i think what motivates me here is uh
you know knowing more about about human
nature i mean i think uh human nature
and human intelligence is a big mystery
it's a scientific mystery
uh in addition to you know philosophical
and etc but you know i'm a true believer
in science so
um
and and and i do have kind of a belief
that for complex systems like like the
brain on the mind
the the way to
understand it is to try to reproduce it
with you know artifacts that you build
because you know what's essential to it
when you try to build it you know the
same way
i've used this analogy before with you i
believe
the same way we only started to
understand uh aerodynamics when we
started building airplanes and that
helped us understand how birds fly
you know so i think there's kind of a
similar process here where
we don't have a theory of a full theory
of intelligence
but building you know intelligent
artifacts will help us perhaps develop
some
you know underlying theory that
encompasses not just artificial
implements but also
human and biological intelligence in
general
you